[Musique]
la famille de sébastien reflet de voyage
après 14 heures de vol
tout ce que souhaite sébastien c'est de
prendre un taxi pour rentrer chez lui
comme la petite famille
beaucoup de bagages sébastien choisi une
fourgonnette mauvaises surprises
le chauffeur de taxi demandent des frais
supplémentaires de 20 $ pour pc la
banquette et charger le véhicule
sébastien est estomaqué un payer plus
cher pour un extra est ce légal
non monsieur chauffeur de taxi ne
peuvent pas exiger un sou de plus que le
montant inscrit au compteur
tous les frais de l'industrie du taxi
sont réglementés mais attention c'est
valable pour le québec c'est le cas
aussi en colombie britannique mais pas
en interne mais sébastien lui a donc
plusieurs recours pour dénoncer la
situation
contrôle routier québec bureau du taxi à
montréal
commission des transports du québec sam
l'histoire ne vous fait pas prendre pour
une valise à cause de vos bagages